make some
well hello everybody did you want a
bonus episode this week you got what is
it a spoiler up Chris it no what about
what are we going to talk this is
another edition of DVD closet another
addition to me the first one I did never
said yeah that the first word did like
three years ago it still counts number
two seam gas just yeah Jackie likes to
walk around with a bag full of [ __ ]
DVDs yeah waiting for us to do the three
years Jackie goes hey guys want some new
DVDs you guys know about this one talk
about oh so yeah uh DVD closet even a
closet [ __ ] let's talk about it like
everyone to know what is ya guys I think
guys been asking for it for a while
everyone who's like what what's DVD well
you're an idiot if you don't know if he
had any positives no this is actually
was a great idea that I think Jackie
came up with three years ago yes and
we've talked about like all we got to do
more DVD closets and then we you know
run all I didn't we didn't do you been
no one else is willing to put DP fits
into their bag and brave / yeah garage
so that is true sir it is a segment
we've talked about maybe we make it
youtube channel yep make it a little 34
minutes segment Jackie oh we had big
plans for the segment good we hoping it
so it's just a crazy bonus up a DVD
closet and it's with the lovely Jackie
Kashian thank you very much for having
me and the premise of DVD closet as you
may have heard Jackie say is a guest
brings DVDs from her collection and we
go through them and sometimes we agree
and then sometimes the guest has to
defend her but sometimes mocking it's
legit a little bit of a tribunal yeah
defend your DVD nerd explain to this
court why you would why that would be
something you would have purchased your
honor please um so today because it is
uh December 11 we're getting into the
holiday season jackie has all it says
Christmas stuff cuz I was raised
christian like a Christian and then we
got over it and but the thing no it's
the Christianity here's the thing it is
Christmas there is no war on Christmas i
will say i'll put the love of God's like
I love the baby huh
I remember that's a kid that was born
not in January I'm Armenian so that's
the great thing about our meeting
Christmas is that you get to keep
talking about it till January sixth and
uh yeah and you have a different Savior
too we have it right it's biff yeah
anywhere number a suit Vanessa it was a
ripoli works at a car lot of gold lot a
lot of gold chains and well the greatest
thing and I've said this before is the
greatest thing about the Armenian Church
is that it's all in Armenian so you
could believe really whatever you want
so the general idea was be like the nice
man in the picture and go get your dad
some coffee that was the entire religion
and I don't mind that religion but I
love Christmas movies and so and I love
almost all I love all holiday movies I
like a holiday movie and sorry what if
we turned out with we're you start out
with what I like to usually start out
which is holiday inn I start out usually
holiday inn is it's got all the holidays
in it I usually start right around
Thanksgiving with it and holiday inn is
with Bing Crosby Fred Astaire and Ginger
that's not ginger rogers who the hell is
that it's uh Marjorie Reynold that's
right Marjorie Reynolds this was her
first leading role and then she got
marginalized again Marjorie poor
Marjorie she was great in it she nailed
it so this came out 1942 it was directed
by mark sandwich of course I'm sure you
all remember mark sandrich sandwich did
um here comes the waves I love a soldier
so proudly we hail uh yeah a bunch of
stuff from the 40s to go rah rah rah and
but the weird thing about this is white
Christmas was introduced in this movie
the song the song white Christmas was
was first introduced into our into our
lives by Bing Crosby and his he has he
has an end that's only open on holidays
and so then every holiday during the
year every holiday like the fourth of
july and washington's birthday and I'd
like to see the balance sheet on that
well there are some mocking about how
he's clearly an entertainer cuz he only
wants to work what 18 days a week a year
and and so he gets to put on a show for
each one on each one's themed the I
believe it is the fourth of July one is
the one that's in blackface and yeah
really and on AMC sometimes they cut
that
seen from it which is an irritant it's
not like we all don't know that
blackface happened and we know that it's
not okay and and and it's the only
decent seen really that the black people
in the movie get cuz they're Mamie who's
the the housekeeper and her little kids
are in that earring that one too and any
you're just like I it isn't great but
it's like putting it's like you remember
an ET when they the photo shopped out
the guns out of the kind of that and
they made them yeah walkie-talkies so
they're pointing walkie-talkies at
everybody it looks ridiculous yeah right
so I mean it's like that it's like it'd
be like trying to airbrush every every
time somebody's smoking out of a movie
or every time someone's drinking or
eating chocolate or whatever the the sin
that you hate and so uh but holiday inn
is actually it's great it's full of and
white Christmas is one of the greatest
toy ever made so I usually like to start
out with that that's a good one and then
this year I actually started out with a
with it with a different one that I that
I traditionally usually end the season
with which is Groundhog Day uh-huh yes
that's a februari that's a that's a
groundhog day a holiday moment you
remember ground I like to bring it out
I'm I keep bringing out the DVD and
holding it up like like we're on
television close close up on this
groundhog day DVD cover and sadly not a
blu-ray none of these so far our blu
rays Groundhog Day 1990 3 herald ramos
of course Bill Murray and mcdowell and
chris elliott that's classic movie and
you know a lovely cameo by Rick Overton
recovery as well um him and Rick do
caminar yes tag-teaming in the in the
diet oh that's right good diner yeah
that is very funny it's a but don't
needle head Ned once you remember dad
the head remember him rise yeah remember
yes doable on skis yet stupido velovsky
he was d did a storytelling show that I
was on he was actually quite interesting
i believe he has a podcast he does i
think he does hey podcast listeners yes
it could happen
oh yeah why do you why would you include
Groundhog Day into like these Christmas
things because it takes a place in the
winter it's a sim I'm a simple woman of
the people i think that's been
established i think cavity film nerds
know that and doesn't it also capture
though like the feeling of like a
Christmas movie if it's a ground it's
got great heart it's got all lets you
find out see what I want out of a
Christmas and the moon and on that's a
great point and the movie ends with a
snow stay wake up and there's and
there's snow everywhere everywhere and
he's an ice sculptor by the end of it
yeah which is really very sort of its
Scrooged yeah I have Scrooged in here
too Scrooge is harder for me to watch
because but I I think Bill Murray is
such a he plays a dick so well but i'm
like i don't i don't actually want to
see that I don't want to feel me I love
Scrooged Scrooged is great it's a it's
and I and I always watch it but it's not
here it is hey I don't know why I need
to look at it but here's it's uh it's
it's also i believe from the 90s yeah
and actually is 19 88 88 no Murray and
Karen Allen that's it music by danny
elfman you guys yeah for that that movie
was directed by richard donner it's a
really fun movie it is a real and they
really do nail it they did it sort of
like oh so funny and it's yet and it's
like an inside Hollywood kind of meta
definitely like kind of pain that were
making this from us really well there's
that the TV shows that he makes likely
major saves Christmas yeah Tara you take
it over the north pole or whatever and
Lee Majors comes in and guns him down
it's pretty funny right and now in the
last two days I just started with in
with a vengeance started watching him
cuz I like to start right around the two
weeks into Christmas I like to before
before you know Christmas Day I like to
really start getting into it and plus i
do go until january sixth that's how
long how are you let's Wendy one of your
decorations start and when do they end
they start two weeks before we're gonna
get our tree on the 10th okay wait
todays the 10th or yesterday was we're
gonna get our country on monday we we
put up our outside decorations right
after Thanksgiving because that long
weekend we have the time to actually put
them up and everything else we can
take your time like we don't have the
tree yet but yeah that's like kind of
our start of the holiday season right
after Thanksgiving I don't like going to
the mall before thanksgiving and seeing
all the decorations up that still
irritates me I know that's been going on
for a while now yeah still don't like it
still don't like it still still would
like it to chill out because
Thanksgiving is I think such an
important I think it's such an important
holiday you guys I really do because of
gratitude because of being thankful for
stuff and because of Turkey all of those
things all of those things are important
and I think we need to give them their
own time that doesn't help retailers as
much a dozen as much day yeah there's
only so much turkey p.m. are willing to
buy haha well what do you guys do what
my sister came up when we were kids she
came up she was like the best marketing
she was probably 11 or 12 when she said
this a marketing complete failure by
mcdonalds the fact that thanksgiving
they do not serve turkey McNuggets with
cranberry dipping sauce she's like I
don't understand she was 11 years old
she was like I don't understand why they
don't offer this at McDonald's as a
seasonal of foodstuff turkey McNuggets
with cranberry dipping sauce it would be
huge I would buy that I would area Yeah
right I make perfect sense I had and for
some reason McDonald's never responded
to her queries I don't think she ever
sent anything up she might have she was
11 she was you know when you're 11 you
say I tell you what I will you send
queries out when you're 11 oh yeah play
on fuel yeah point of order point of
order mcdonald she's an 11 year old she
was the only nine year old i do used to
pour over the real estate section
remember those newspaper print things
that that yeah at the grocery store and
you'd get it all over your hands she's
like what do you think of this property
and now she's running dupont yeah yeah
really she's a financial advisor and and
RBC day Russia yeah right and enormously
suggest yes surprising no manages
pricing absolutely hundreds of millions
of dollars exactly um I this normally I
used to do a tradition I started uh
where I'd set my tree up on thanksgiving
day oh and then cuz might you have fake
trees do you guys do fake ID faker no
real real tree which is white would you
really gotta wait yeah I go I go I
bought a fake tree like 15 year
go um because I i read this [ __ ] this
is so great I read this thing in the
Sierra Club and they weighed
environmental impact of real tree yep vs
fake tree and right over the life of 10
years a fake tree edges it out ever so
slightly if you figure in driving the
footprint yeah Pratt attend to and front
is genuinely that it's not huge oh yeah
it's it's not a huge it's a weekend we
do every other year this is a real tree
here which is why we got away yeah I
don't know why so I bought this tree at
you mix it up yeah i bought a tree at
target for like 40 50 bucks like in 2001
or some brian or two and now so the last
three since I this is the first year
i've set it up since I've been divorced
because I was holiday yeah sure [ __ ]
and I had a little recover I had a
little two-foot plug-in already
decorated thing well that thing I bought
when I was a kid my 20s and so like a
tabletop tree like a table to me so that
was my like sad divorce guy Christmas
trees for the last ah but this year you
know girlfriend things are nice set up a
Christmas tree does she get one of the
ones that has the lights like built-in
on the branches we do know we've got one
that because the thing is Annie was like
I want a tree that looks fake and I was
like it has to be green though he's like
I kind of want it to be pink or silver
something I'm like please can you it can
look sooo at all it is is it's a pole
with light like sticking out like slight
stems and then we also have garlands
that have lights that are worked into
him that we wrap around it like like a
Charlie Brown Christmas yes and we so we
fill it out and make it into a triangle
with this fake garland that is all it's
entirely lights it like lights up our
living room and then we bought at Macy's
cost as much as the tree a star that is
also lit and so the whole thing just
glows like a power plant in the middle
of our it is the greatest fig tree in
the world and and then we do an in
Tiffany scene we always do it Queen
Amidala is usually a merry and Charlie
Brown is usually Joseph and then we do
like I have dr. girlfriend is
of the angels uh just take like
different action figure thank you don't
like you do I am I tried to do that it
was frowned upon a little bit yours
because because she does we get the
regular manger but there I you know I
supplement it with a Grimlock and
daredevil and yes we have a little Ewok
as the baby Jesus yeah cuz it was an it
was at a pouch I'm one of the one of the
San people or Ewok people not an Ewok it
was a San people and this is the Mancini
castle though let's get to it's a
wonderful life you guys the martini
castle is is that I just watched so I'd
so in the last in the last day I watched
the bishops wife with Cary Grant Loretta
Young and David Niven who you guys seen
that no no why the Bishop's wife
horribly remade as the preacher
preacher's wife right with denzel and
Whitney Whitney Houston yeah yeah dude
Denzel as Kari grant i will not do
Whitney Houston as Loretta you will not
that did not work that Loretta Young is
amazing David Niven is amazing Cary
Grant is amazing and um this is a
beautiful it's a it's is it Capra no I
don't know who it is it's Henry caught
koster isn't what year that is 1947 do
you know what's fascinating to about
when they would put these DVD covers
together they would even though it's a
black-and-white film they would put the
cover in color oh yeah just to remember
colorization Oh in fact you have a DVD
that was on the front lines of the
colorization debate The Wonderful Life
no the bells of st. Mary oh that was
actually one of the ones that they you
know turn was showcasing like look how
great this movie looks in color right
and thank they worried backed it away
yeah remember jit my favorite Jay Leno
not a lot of people say this my favorite
Jay Leno joke is was from I believe in
the middle of that debate which was I
think in the middle late 80s when when
colorization first came out and he he
was just subbing for Johnny Carson and
he came out and it was Christmastime and
he goes hey you know the colorization
very controversial but i think that they
did an amazing job they colorized the
first 10 minutes of The Wizard of Oz and
the audience just gasped does occur
news it was and then he had a punch line
but I didn't care what a setup ever
because it was just the greatest I was
like well that jokes done ya know what
else needs to write another joke about
colorization the best premise of the
joke ever so yeah so the bishops wife is
a very beautiful it's a you know it's um
David Niven is he he prays that he needs
help building this giant [ __ ]
Cathedral and and so Kari grant shows up
as the angel Nivens always building
something bridges or cuts he up to that
guy's well he works he with you likes to
stay busy likes to work with his hands
and and so it's a it's a very it's a
very sweet movie and it's very there's a
great scene in it with the guy place a
professor are you are you on the IMDb
page yes who plays the professor he's a
great uh he's a great character actor um
Monty Woolley maybe and but he makes
this great lion he says this great line
about how this this woman who's
supposedly gonna finance the the the
cathedral she got him fired from the
University for being too political and
he's like he's got some great line about
how I have been political since like
Nero and because he's it's all he's an
agent history professor I got niven
confuses Alec Guinness Alec innocent
bridge over the river oh right yeah
ready yeah well that'll have him I'm
sure someone's yelling at the right but
yeah I'm happy Thunder dreams so uh but
it's wonderful so I watched I did bells
of st. Mary's of course I remember even
as a kid you remember the but did you
see the bells it's been a long time
since Robin ingrid bergman by step
mother used to always say oh don't all
been wish that nuns look like ingrid
bergman and i remember even as a child
thinking why would they want a nun to
look like ingrid bergman they want
someone look like a date to look like a
bird burgers and but she i guess maybe
the ingrid bergman looking none is not
the one that's gonna beat the [ __ ] out
of you yes yes possibly that's where and
that's the one you think you could maybe
turn
nice you know really run it yeah you
don't really want to be another just cuz
yeah you haven't met the right person
yet yes this is your boyfriend but he's
never around yeah and this this movie
has nine plots this movie the bells of
st. Mary's by the way also have never
seen a priest that looks like Bing
Crosby right and and and also things and
does a little soft shoe yeah he's cast
and and several off-color jokes that
they sort of apologetically break the
fourth wall and kind of look at the
camera a little bit it's almost road to
save Mary's say yes the road to st.
Mary's because he makes a couple of
jokes and he doesn't like an ice slide
toward the camera is like all right well
Bob Hope's not in this movie but I know
you've watched them I know you watch
them it's a little off color yeah but
and it's it's but there's like there's a
story about raising look it when raising
boys as too many nuns raising boys
there's that whole plot you're like oh
they're going to be sissies and then
there's this whole thing about a sort of
a divorced little girl who wants to go
to the Catholic school Ingrid Bergman
has tuberculosis there's a beautiful
like what is going on and and then
there's this whole thing out how he's
actually come to this school so that he
can close the school down and sell it to
a corporation to turn it into a parking
lot I mean there's a lot of things going
on bells the same areas at least four
different plots you guys and then the
classic it's a wonderful life which only
I watch it every year every three years
I cry the other two years I just want to
kill uncle Billy I don't know you guys
have seen it's wonderful of course yeah
there we go so uncle Billy of course a
monumental alcoholic idiot that everyone
around him is enabled and no one tells
uncle Billy to get his [ __ ] together and
sometimes it just drives me nuts but
this year I just kids it's been I don't
know it's I got very emotional the
couple of scenes when he's sitting there
with his dad and his dad's like hey you
gonna come back from college and maybe
work for the the building and Loan and
he's like no no not
do it now you're you you get you this
little two-bit nickel and dime you know
savings and loan and his dad's like well
I think we're really I think we're
really changing some lives with our
their little two-bit and I'm like I just
silent tears course he does like you did
you did mr. Bailey you were very big
helper as good as it's a wonderful life
is I will always argue that I think mr.
Smith goes to Washington is a better
film from Fred a better Chris a better
Christmas movie no not a better
Christmas movie just film in general
it's a horrible life is I mean it's
still it still has all the I mean it
still kind of works i mean i don't know
and the it hits all the right girly does
yeah and there's when uncle Billy loses
the eight grand though and the fact in
the Hays Code completely thrown out the
window because mr. Potter gets to keep
the eight grand he gets to stay in power
at the end of the movie and you're like
I don't approve I don't approve of no
come up and but but I you know it's a
when mr. Gower comes in and there and
everybody's giving up the money and the
25 grand is gonna get wired from hija
Sam Wainwright come on you gotta yeah at
that point that's good times yes Zuzu's
petals is the name of my sisters band is
that your sisters band yeah she was out
of minneapolis and nineties yeah oh my
god i saw zoozoos Pallister you saw them
perform they were that was where they
came up with those rose petals yeah
there was a famous name of a band like
everyone was like the greatest name of
any band of Zuzu's petals everyone in
minneapolis said that yeah all through
the oh yeah they were like one of the
first all-girl punk bands Jesus in like
the late 80s and early get out there and
and are they on Spotify they still
getting some sound exchange money I
hoped I hope so is a great book that um
it was my sister collina would and Lori
Lynn Dean and Linda forget Linda's last
name but Lori Lynn Dean wrote a book
couple years ago called pedal pushers
yeah which is an amazing book if you
want to read what it was like for them
as these young women in their 20s is an
all-girl like punk band driving around
in a van doing bar gigs and what the
standing next to husker du yeah exactly
and performing with all those bright
like probably being compared to the
runaways yeah there's that The Supremes
the J who else you know like didn't the
Jayhawks or whatever come out of
Minneapolis her yeah but wait that
sounds about right Oh music not being my
life yeah I'm pretty sure but it's it's
a it's a fantastic book it was me
fantastic for me cuz I'm yeah what's it
called as pedal pushers okay yeah I
should get that and it's about the
Zuzu's petals it so that's awesome
tastic book but it yeah it's a wonderful
life it's a wonderful life it's great so
like all all the short all the short
cartoony stuff right I mean are you
starting at Thanksgiving i watch charlie
brown's thanksgiving actually at
halloween i watch the great pumpkin and
then it's thanksgiving and then it's the
Charlie Brown Christmas you know there's
a second charlie brown thanksgiving
where it shows like all the Pilgrims and
how they died yeah it's like there's a
really weird like cast yes yeah
genuinely they don't air that one
anymore oh and this one has syphilis
blah yeah it does it does it has to me
Wow oh yeah as does the pumpkin the crib
the pumpkin one has a shitty a second
one on the blu-ray because I have the
collection right the deluxe holiday
collection with remastered classics and
it's their great except for if you hit
accidentally play all all of a sudden
you see some some just shitty everything
successful gets a sequel whether it's
warranted or not whether it's warranted
or not and then of course we get Rudolph
frosty yeah the Santa Claus is coming to
town named the shitty sequel in that
cave at the Rudolph would know that
frosty frosty yeah frosty there was a
there was a think it's frosty returns
its it literally makes no sense if you
don't watch it and but I think Danny
DeVito I guess it is like it's insane
right because that is also in this I
have the deluxe because this is frosty
returns is in here yeah and it's dump
these ones the the Charlie Brown and
these Rudolph ones with that weird what
I don't know what you call stop motion
animation animation that that like
defined my childhood because that was
like every year and it heralded the
season you knew it was Christmas time
when these specials came on TV like all
right plan around it oh yeah yeah yeah
yar was a pain in the ass and then have
one and then you knew one went one
growing up once you watch those specials
then you would get the Sears toy catalog
and you would get to go through through
and look through everything it was like
these were things we did every year as
kids mm-hmm we got the oh this is not a
good stir I don't know why I would tell
and I we would get the Sears catalog but
we never got toys because there were too
many of us we always got clothes and but
we would my sister [ __ ] story it all
works out guys I have a [ __ ] load of
toys now but my sister and I would pick
one thing from every [ __ ] page cuz we
might as well and and I'd be like I
don't want anything on this page as you
go you have to pick something because
we're Americans she wouldn't say that
but though you could kind of Yash and
but but yeah it was we never did we
never did pick anything so I was seven
we didn't need toys by the time I was
said such [ __ ] yeah what
seven-year-old plays with toys exactly
who's got time for toys now here's the
weird one you guys here's the weird the
because the new generation of kids are
watching the DreamWorks holiday
collection ah I don't know if you have
seen like shrek the halls i have i've
seen everyone in that way yes uh-huh III
think my favorite though is the Kung Fu
Panda holiday you are correct though I
like them my little the dragon one the
dragon yeah pretty good that one's good
merry Madagascar is so do they these
weren't in theaters no no no released on
DVD and also streaming uh you can get
them on streaming too so it's like just
for little short films they're not full
features yeah they're like specials yeah
they're like specials they're like
old-timey specials you like kung fu
panda holiday guy I want to watch this
it is good good it's actually pretty
good and yeah dragons holiday yeah
dragons holiday is good the gift of
Night Fury that sounds awesome yeah yeah
they're pretty great and and that's a
good thing and then of course you know
you got the Grinch the green flash is a
classic another ones sounds like
ingrained in my childhood right and you
know if you look to it like the charlie
brown one it has such a Christian
message if anyone tried to do that now
on regular network TV and
made it a kibosh show yeah it would over
me that or more heavy-handed it would
have to be what it would either
VeggieTales the hell out of right or
they would be like no let's put a
menorah over there in the corner and or
some damn thing right and and but the
Grinch always good always get the Grinch
and I sometimes you know and nobody's
ever I mean everybody's pretty good
support where they have all their crap
stolen which I thought was pretty nice
of them what do you mean what you don't
want for the Grinch yeah and the Grinch
10 skills there's just things there's
stuff yeah yeah there's gonna be other
who whistles young your life and lower
cut speaking of things and feast oh
right hey what you do that we're here
check it out we have a sponsor great sir
um hoverboard yes we want to talk to you
guys about shari's berries now they did
send us berries again always always fun
to get cherries berries and they're
greatly on your front door you're like
oh my god this is great oh my grades
recognize the box now they get all
excited I think your kids can smell it
yeah street they don't last long it's
just a lot of berries it's with
forgotten share with different like
types of coatings there's like a
chocolatey goodness there was some of
them have like a white chocolate type
coating and then there's a nuts on of
them and they're really really good
they're get in toppings like chocolate
chips and chopped nuts okay it's their
amazing they're amazing they're there
they're not just strawberries like other
kinds of berries or is it all stronger
these specifically or berries however
shari's berries has other stuff if you
want to get the everything from like
cookies to other things like areand it
like there another yeah business why
would I do that like like yeah like
those two guys that all guys it also
said dude they also send food but aren't
you answering they come but I'm
basically for shari's berries the the
the chocolaty dipped strawberries are
the flagship product of the yeah
excellent of their company and here's
the thing though we always like when
shari's berries is a sponsor because we
can give deals to the fans so it starts
at 1999 which is a forty percent off
savings but you can double the berries
for just ten dollar
more to get this deal go to Barry's calm
and use our special code C F and so I
mean you're in for a penny in for a
pound you may as well W Barrett got this
they got a whole section of gourmet
Christmas bestsellers like dipped
cheesecake trio and half dozen fancy
strawberries they've got six handmade
snowmen brownie pops what these look
great if anything up in a peppermint
bark do they do anything Christmas
caramel pretzel rods okay they've got a
little and some of this stuff actually
sells out like you go to the website and
some of the stuff it's so popular that
you know it literally is like they've
got hand decorated mini christmas
cookies those like awesome holiday
french macaroons oh man this is awesome
it's all this Christmas thing like if
you're gonna have any sort of if you're
having a war on Christmas party right
gray prius is ammunition this is an
occasion for your look that the hand
decorated christmas ornament cookies
were 3999 there now on sale for 1999 yes
just coupon code CFN there's gonna be
more deals yeah absolutely i come up and
now the only way to get these this
amazing offer the sharis berries that
start at 1999 because normally they
start more expensive go to Barry's com
berr IES calm click on the microphone in
the top right hand corner and type in
CFN ok and then essentially start
shopping from there yes and then I know
you'll get all the deals in the deal so
can go you know big Christmas baskets
with fruit nuts they write everything on
here especially for people you don't
know what to get for them if you like
them a lot yeah I me I exactly you know
there's like whole stores full of that
where you're like I really like you but
I guess I'm gonna buy you a compass or a
sextant like you don't think like you
can like the fanciest and but these are
at ever who doesn't like berries you're
never gonna go wrong I sent these to my
like nieces birthday last year wives
mothers day there you go and they never
last they're gone they're called day and
no one's ever like oh my god yeah
enough with the chocolate covered
strawberries ah the word yeah so okay
coupon code CFN yes calm all right
Jackie what else do you have in your DVD
closet this is another new one that
everybody should freaking see have you
seen this is what I have not seen prep
and landing you guys prep and landing no
one knows stealth like an elf huh huh it
isn't an elf on a shelf asshat either
those no wait a minute is this I think I
have seen this is the short film where
like they're too they're almost like elf
secret agents yeah well then they do
prep and landing for Santa they show up
and they make sure that everything's
working out they they I think that they
make sure everything the kids are all
asleep and make sure everybody it's
adorable yeah and it's it's um de folie
and Sarah oh I did see this one yes yes
from Scrubs uh-huh so good so funny
summer thinking and it is yeah it's it's
essentially this guy wants to be the
director of the he's got a the the the
bad guy elf in this he's not a bad guy
he's just a guy with some ambition man
and he's just sick of being in prep and
landing he's sick of it man he's been in
it for like 100 years and he wants to be
like the director of naughty or the
director of nice and so he goes in and
he's just he liked right he sabotages a
thing and then Santa has to come in and
save him and he's working with a new
rookie things are it's really good stuff
you guys it's a it's a quality quality
moment here we go it's like when Dirty
Harry did the one with Tyne Daly you
know it it's um this is this is always
another short one that's always good
every year it is the Colbert Christmas
oh man I decisions it was such a classic
take on the old 70s Chris variety show
it was so perfect I was hoping that he
would do one every [ __ ] year for the
rest of his life sadly probably a lot of
work so i can't remember what year this
came up but i always got that after five
or six years ago I always got this
full-time gig on CBS that's probably
taken up a couple minutes of his name
yeah exactly so this is seven years old
the colbert christmas greatest gift of
all and
cut a red sweater in a pipe like I just
it is it is absurd and it's a toby
keith's Feist is in it well Bill Murray
filled that void with the bill merry
christmas special on Netflix ivanson
network science it either holy funny OC
but there's ones that are out this year
that I haven't seen crumpets and I
haven't seen that Netflix one um I want
to see all those I'm talking about
crevice on the regular episodes now
there you go and there are always a
thousand different versions of a
Christmas carol that I like to watch
every year there's the one from the 50s
which I for some reason cannot could not
find my copy of the famous one with the
with the the black and white and whose
name I'm spacing probably should have
looked it up knew I was gonna be a
christmas carol from 1950 we didn't
bring the DVD so it doesn't count it
doesn't count DVD closet and uh there's
you know the Muppet Christmas Carol okay
great let's talk about the Muppet
Christmas Carol okay second because I
watched it again yeah probably about a
year or two ago and here's what I found
absolutely fascinating about a muppets
christmas carol first of all i really
liked it yeah i think it's fantastic
holds up really it holds up really well
and Michael Caine is Scrooge yep now
what is fascinating what Michael Caine
is he generally takes whatever script is
offered depending on where it shoots
yeah and you can often see him walk
through roles this role he didn't walk
through at all no he he put like it was
he said he acted in this it was so
intense like just him with his like icy
glare at the Muppets and my things like
you believed it like he's no he was just
full of rage at the rat and his rat
accountants yeah yeah it was it was yeah
it is he is chillin I just seemed like
when he turns around uh it's around it
just stares and all of them of is just
like shudder just cuz he's glaring uh
it's hilarious because he he does not
phone it in why does like it looks like
he it looks like he's acting with like
like Olivier like it and it's a frog you
know that's that but that's what he puts
into the determined players Bob Cratchit
yeah and and he goes back in time and
you get to see ya you know and the eagle
plays the headmaster
yeah oh are you kidding me from what he
goes you know any better good season
he's a boy and it was one of the it's
just sad and it's yeah pathos oh there's
and it follows the original story the
other thing what I found fascinating
about it is there's a lot of quotes and
like actual passages from the the book
read from the book so that it sound like
aah we don't need you know we got the
regular sure we'll just right at you
know a goofy script for and then no I
didn't they were actually um they they
were honoring the source material they
honored to Soria it's not like they
didn't I mean they they have the Dickens
story yeah they really did they didn't
take it from like when Fonzie was
screwed right and then just take and
lift that right and but I'd also keeping
super true to it I don't know if you
guys have ever seen the mr. Magoo no
Carol mr. Magoo christmas carol is
amazing I don't think I've seen it since
I was a kid is that one where a tiny tim
goes razzleberry dressing yes yes it is
my friend yes it is and here and it's
beaut it's a beautiful dvd/blu-ray quite
honestly it's a collector's ish it's
it's full of holiday cheer according to
their own packaging and put its delivers
right it comes with it comes with a with
a frameable off guard for some resigned
by mr. Magoo signed by mr. big wait yeah
there's an autograph signed by Bacchus
the guy who draws mr. Magoo all should
have been I don't know it is the voice
recording but it's got like a bag is
just a boy yeah draw some drops to mr.
Reagan mr. Howell it was also an
animator
I have no idea that's what he was doing
between takes on Gilligan's Island it's
like I can't voice this until I draw it
sort oh this is by the way that that
interaction is the complete definition
I'm doing a new podcast with the Lord
Kilmartin unnoticed it's going to go up
in January and it's essentially you know
there's I don't know if you guys know
this there's a lot of podcasts were but
a couple of white guys get together and
talk about being stand-up comics not
familiar with those never mari Kilmartin
are gonna be a couple of white women
talking about stand-up comedy show does
a step in in a direction that lateral
move lateral I don't think it's I don't
think we're freeing the slaves here
could you know what you call it a half
twist heads none there's a some work is
being done then here's a rando one or
guess remember elf oh yeah club out one
of my favorite Christmas movie what are
your favorite just because of the heart
what do you love about it what I love
about it is it's a modern movie that
captures the heart of the classic
Christmas movies yeah I love the fact
that it's its first of all it's saying
that the North Pole exists Will Ferrell
yep by the way this is james caan and
James Caan is great as his dad this is
dan it's it's classic bowl for others
and there's really also i'm gonna bring
up the thing on another DB that came up
in two thousand jon favreau director
drex it so that's really funny yeah new
heart yeah Lisa's stepdad uh-huh Deb
dead which is awesome I mean you've got
great you've got great stuff in the
start to finish this thing yeah really
it's great it's it's a real solid Chris
but as her as Santa Claus and again Will
Ferrell he does not phone it in you
believe him yeah the gimbals manager is
faizon love there's some scenes in there
where he's just a classic faizon love is
this like you know wearing his
department store manager
give them great lines man there's a
[ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] so good so good
the classics lat last two classics
there's a miracle at thirty-fourth
Street always great the remake of that
was terrible I don't know if you saw the
remake of miracle and 30 didn't see the
remake know okay so it made for TV movie
right it wasn't it was sadly I believe
in the it was almost um maybe it was
made 40 i don't know i watched what I
could never quite get that into Maria
Maureen O'Hara didn't yet never grabbed
you Natalie what is it as a child yeah I
just that's what she played she played a
child in this cuz she was a child anyway
buddy well that's good acting is what
yes it is yeah that was really good
method she's stuck the landing you guys
and so what didn't you like about it I
think it was one of those things for
whatever reason you know my kid I'm not
that into black some black-and-white
movies I just couldn't get into its
rightful life I always I always did
because there's just something about
Jimmy Stewart where I'd he's super
likable I don't yeah the guy who plays
the lead in this john Payne he's very
much not Cary Grant like it's not an
a-list actor and I don't know I'm sure
he went on cuz he's very you know he's
got regular features for a handsome guy
yeah but I lower paste movie is there a
lower place no reason yeah it's a
wonderful life is like boom boom boom
boom boom there's something always going
down yeah and I and I guess it's what my
first inclination into why it's sort of
a time travel movie and I love time
travel travel type their parallel
universe yeah I didn't think of it that
way but you're right it is a time travel
movie yeah orrow Noriko elseworlds yeah
like you know because that always
happens in time travel of like well if
we go back yeah change this then what's
gonna happen what's he gonna look like
well the the remake of Miracle on
thirty-fourth street was it would be
like trying to do a remake of Last
Starfighter kind of because the the the
main scene in Miracle on thirty-fourth
Street is the they prove Santa's
existence through the US mail I don't
think I'm ruining something from 1947 by
the way I should really really and but
the but in the remake I
they use email or something I think it's
like I think they they don't do mail
they I forget what the conceit was to
prove that Santa existed at the end of
miracle the remake of Miracle on
thirty-fourth Street but it was terrible
it was like ha first I was like let's
just still use the mail that's a
perfectly because I tend to love a movie
that ends with a court battle like uh
mr. deeds goes to town I don't know if
you ever saw that with Gary Cooper where
he's at he's being tried for being
insane and then at the end of it she
admits that she loves him and he'll
appear until great and I so but instead
in a courtroom that's it then you know
that's standing it's also that one of
those movies that it's a product of its
time you can't remake it it doesn't
necessarily hold up now you have to view
it with those kinds of glasses where
there was no email and the only way to
communicate was with letters from yeah
from the poland bags and bags of letters
show up yes in a very profound effect
yes ya know one of my favorite scenes in
Miracle on thirty-fourth street is that
first scene where the macys I mean
there's there's the macy's Gimbels thing
I don't know if you guys had weird
Gimbels in milwaukee right as a kid we
had Nancy's and uh in philly and we had
macy's as well but it was but the macy's
Gimbels rivalry was very real in
Milwaukee when I was a kid and but my
one of my favorite scenes is the Macy's
Day Parade and I love a parade I love
approach yes the beat of the drums get
it out and and then this is a terrible
movie that i watch occasionally every
year uh-huh not every year I can't do it
it's the actual white Christmas one with
Bing Crosby and I think it's danny kaye
and it's yeah Bing Crosby Danny Kaye
Rosemary Clooney who is George Clooney's
aunt and uh Bing Crosby Danny Kaye
rosemary cloning vera-ellen and it is
and the lyric and music by Irving Berlin
but it's such it's kind of one of those
rah-rah World War two remakes they
essentially they took the good song from
holiday inn I was going to say that like
they probably that song was such a hit
from Holland
like we should make a whole movie around
this song around this and then for some
reason get rid of Fred Astaire even
though I love Danny Kaye for you got why
would you get rid of Fred Astaire what
do you out of here this is this is my
favorite like 40s or 50s a movie
discription like this sums up so many of
these movies a successful song and dance
team hahaha become romantically involved
with a sister act believe that sister
song is from this Sister Sister don't
get between me and my mister yeah yeah
that's just good writing you guys kind
of and then the last one I brought is a
modern-day miracle this is it die hard
oh great Christmas it is a Christmas
movies a Christmas movie not really
realizing it was a Christmas movie when
it when it came out and now it has gone
into cannon as an actual christmas movie
diehard all alan rickman all the time i
would like uh he makes the movie yeah
it's it's so good suit mr. Takagi like
the diction having its Snape he's just
he's just all forget Alan Rickman is the
greatest we've also got you've got
wonderful things in terms of the spirit
of Christmas yeah what's important yep
his marriage gets healed yes right you
know they all kind of fall back in love
cuz he has to save his wife there's a
great William Atherton one of the
greatest movie dicks of all time but
doesn't he look exam Atherton who played
now who did he play did he play but the
journalist he's the [ __ ] journalist
easy [ __ ] journalist there was
awesome Thornburg also played Hornburg
dick Thornburgh uh but there was also a
guy who played the police inspector oh
yeah well he's a great I'll Paul Gleason
is is is the classic dick he was the
dick in in Breakfast Club right Paul
Gleason isn't a maze he played an
[ __ ] and every thug in that movie
like every like hired mercenary yep
you've seen it a hundred other movies is
like a hired mercenary or a thought oh
yeah thank you Mike oh I recognize that
guy that guy that guy's my thing about
about the guy who played the journalist
in the guy
play the police cop of the police cop
inspector and one of the Johnson
Brothers uh the Vietnam Johnson brother
from FBI that was such a funny scene
that what's his face's daddy's got the
horrible uh the pockmarks skin but he's
yeah but get this they all three of
those guys have the same haircut and I
remember watching that when I was a kid
going is that the same actor hahaha cuz
they all have that wavy do and I was
like why would they get three guys who
kind of look like that same white guy
cuz they only went to hire one style
maybe maybe that was a it could've been
a stylist problem and Robert Davi is
Special Agent Johnson Ryan grand Bush is
the other age of Judge Special Agent no
relation no relation I was six years old
you did just like Vietnam us like I was
six years old dick yes so all such a
great line heart bochner is the is the
cokehead a hotshot example that tries to
negotiate uh I do million-dollar deals
for breakfast I could negotiate with
this T road rash Jesus Christ oh yeah
and that what about but I'm the nice
product placement when he gets thick the
coke guys one can give them to you yeah
just like who's the limo driver who's
the actor oh that's a great I think
because I think that was a gill your
junior remember the Christmas song was
so christmas in hollis what Chris was in
Queens no I'm sorry clarence gilyard jr
is the guy who is the the nerd the nerd
black nerd block word that's it playing
for um he's working with Hans Gruber
right and so the the the kind of the he
was he was little he was a little guy
and that he uses he uses his powers for
good he uses limo for good at the end of
it we crashes right into the side of
that van and then who played the brother
that shows up at the end of it all right
well okay so there's the there's the
black cop who's a famous character actor
that's uh yeah that is Reginald V
Johnson reg yeah there we go that cold
is still hold on oh God and so the and
then
Arjun L Powell sergeant al Powell who
knows exactly what's in a Twinkie that
guy that guy's good that's good guys
great and then uh accidentally shot a
kid and felt remorse you know like cops
ought to and and then and then who's the
giant blond who was the giant blond who
had the brother who looked like Kurt
Braunohler remember the kurt braunohler
was Alexander guten off right he was the
long hair right and then his brother who
gets killed now hobo now I have a
machine gun yeah there was I forget he
looks exactly like Kurt Braunohler I
don't know every comic yeah anyway yeah
I love die hard it's a really fun movie
and it was also one of those movies
where you didn't realize how fun it was
gonna be until he saw it because it was
a weird marketing we're just all looks
like a regular thriller yeah looks like
a regular action yeah but then when you
when you watch her Michael this is
really fun this is just something wasn't
groundbreaking didn't establish did it
establish quips come to LA climb through
the media was a boy yeah come to LA
we'll have a few let come to the coast
we'll have a few laughs while he's
climbing through her all right it was
and it was his first big break after
moonlighting right wasn't it yeah yeah
John McTiernan directed it i think it
was his sort of first big movie as well
it was his it was McTiernan first like
well he did nomads and he did predator
but it was his then from there McTiernan
did hunt for red october oh wow when did
last action hero which is a bummer but
then he know he sort of uh he was the
big 80s yeah west action here didn't
help Alan Rickman's career after die
hard see that and I thought I had seen
all of all of elements work well you
have no reason to see that yeah fair
enough weed okay I don't think any one
considers it canon okay Alan Rickman and
that John McCain real quick he directed
a movie called the 13th warrior with
Antonio by remember that movie which is
an awesome film is it it's it's one of
these movies it nobody liked it it got
panned it didn't do well on the box
office I don't think and I saw it and I
was like this is awesome
hired all these Viking dudes to just go
out and just it's just great yeah Viking
sword fight there's a great line in that
movie where Antonio Banderas picks up
the sword and it's too heavy goose I
can't lift the sword and the Viking goes
grow stronger just Viking J up it's it's
amazing that's so what what movies don't
I have what movie should i see that i
didn't that I didn't bring um and
specials and specials I would say the
Black Adder Christmas special oh yeah I
have actually never seen which is
amazing because it also tells the story
of a Christmas carol but blackadder
starts as the nicest man in all England
and as that progresses he gets meaner
and nastier and then it becomes like
Black Adder at the end so reverses oh
that's yeah cuz the the the the first
ghost that comes to visit him is like a
well yeah you don't need any visions
you're doing great i'm gonna want to
haunt all the other people he goes well
let me see my ancestors and he sees how
horrible is ancestors were yeah but how
they always got ahead he's like well if
yeah but they all got a head even though
they did horrible things is like well
technically yeah but alright I'm not
showing you anymore I'm leaving Oh God
so it's it's great but one hits one
ghost after another turning him into
screw yes yes yes that is really good so
okay mine is Bad Santa that's great
that's a great movie Billy Bob Thornton
Bernie Mac Lauren Graham oh jeez
boyfriend Lauren grams in that she's
awesome tony cox I'd like it's it hits
the right mix of being completely
inappropriate but also really funny john
ritter's great yeah oh yeah I mean it's
really getting to see a bunch of you
know yeah yeah people it's super dark
yeah it's definitely done yeah it's your
mean and dark and the other thing other
special i would recommend watching is
December twentieth at the Hollywood
improv
haha our wars holiday special which we
will be uh commenting on yes I'm a live
commentary and uh if someone in this
room can check their old person can have
a paper thing that that oh it has it's
gonna but it's got this ring on the on
the corner of it then you just open
different pages it was every year I like
to buy a new calendar it's nice this
year's theme is it's called the reading
woman and it has different pictures of
women reading in it and some of them are
from the US women shouldn't be allowed
to read but that's how old this thing
they found some seriously old photos you
guys in the 1840s when cameras were just
invented they were like together your
recipes on three-by-five cards i did
send me a three but how do you backup
your your book on the cloud on the club
wall I just hold it above my head yeah
and I'm just like it's raining work hey
it's a fun you guys I have to check my
book to see if I can cut I've never seen
this Star Wars spell oh it's your havin
for a long time and I'm not watching it
I felt the same way I'm like I've encino
I'm gonna wait okay sorry that is uh
December 20 / 20 to 80 year old lab the
improv lab yes so hopefully um miss Kay
Shin will check her be joining will you
be joining it'll be good you guys gonna
go see that star wars hear there's a new
Star Wars movies coming out well we're
going to Australia to see it a day early
oh my god you or not are you really
we're leaving Monday night Cass Public
Register steel Saunders yes deal yes is
set up this whole thing like almost a
year ago and I was on his show you
talked about this was last year he goes
you know the star wars fan club in
Australia is setting up a midnight
screening at 1201 on the seventeenth
which because movies are released a day
earlier there they release on thursday
yeah so that means Wednesday night
December 16th yeah technically you can
see it we can see it and I just threw
out and he goes and I'm gonna try to set
up doing a live podcast I said oh man
well Chris and I gotta come out we'll
get to a mash
up and we'll do a spoiler app yeah so we
just sort of laughed and talked about
that as it got closer we realized it
would be comedy film nerds episode three
hundred okay very nice live spoiler up
so it's now happening we were good at
wii and we talked about it and we are
like trying to get sponsors then we said
like maybe three weeks ago four weeks
ago said we don't have the money it's
not going to happen oh yeah do it a fan
in Iowa yeah Eric Eric hi Eric hey Eric
goes here's five grand I want you to go
I want you to go Jesus Eric do you
listen to the dork now anyway jackass so
uh that's awesome we're flying there
it's beautiful so we were gonna really
we're gonna record the episode starting
about three a.m. at Sheamus O'Toole's
irish pub yeah right next door to the
theater right um there's gonna be a
bunch of Steel is bringing a bunch of
comics on we're gonna rotate guests in
and we're having to comedy film nerds
writers flying in from Sydney so it'll
be CJ Johnson and Dean Hagelin oh
they're actually flying in for it too oh
that's awesome record that from three
it'll go till about 4 30 then we're
gonna go you guys gonna get there a
couple days early so you can sleep for a
minute about every day early okay dares
we've gotta do press we're gonna be on
now we're getting interviewed were
getting interviewed TV special oh my god
about the two you know they live like
four channels over there so like I was
on I was on a TV show one time nine
weeks later on the other side of the
continent I was in Perth I was in the
glass house this is a back of the 12th
century when I was in Australia so I was
I think 2005 nine weeks later in Perth a
child recognized me on the street yeah I
felt like I had been on television in
the 70s yeah cuz there's only four
journals in like what you on that thing
and I was like mmm there was another
thing that we're doing something a
shannon 7 in in on Sydney they're
interviewing us as the crazy Americans
coming over to watch this that's awesome
well our episode will post about 6am
melbourne time on the seventeenth which
is about 11 so we're going to do 6am and
the 17 so it's going to be about 11am on
the
sixth wednesday the six california time
yes guys wednesday days your decoder
ring yes spinning we're time traveling
to see it early that's all you need to
do a spoiler up will be up on Wednesday
to 16th America time yes Jesus Christ uh
nobody's gonna listen to that yeah the
next day after we've all seen it in God
I was looking forward to that thank God
they did it yeah so I was on um I did
marilu henner his radio program
yesterday to talk about it and we were
talking about I was like you know people
are already lining up to see Star Wars
like outside and we're talking about all
those people are crazy and then they go
yeah but you're going to Australia to
see it a day early why are you making
fun of those people right no decide to
be fair then we're gonna be in a hotel
we're not we're not get what I gotta be
camping on this we arrived the morning
of the 16th so it may be that night we
have a press interview at two thirty and
then sleeping and sleeping until about
nine so right you might get a good four
or five hours in yeah okay well that
will be ready which is actually perfect
because will still be sort of on
American time get a four hour nap that
could work so then that should work yeah
we should be fine at four in the morning
get a meter pie and go see where's he
gonna be in Sydney uh not Melbourne
Melbourne zone oh good all right yes
giant imax theater go see the hawks yeah
and so that's the only sport i like that
AFL Footy thank you anyway so uh this is
uh that's in amana a lot of christmas
movie excellent well that was a that was
a time well spent putting those together
oh yeah yeah yeah thank you very much
where can people find you on the
internet and he live upcoming shows
Jackie Keisha calm and dark forest calm
but that I'm I can check your physical
book alright League rarick come on over
to the house yeah and and i'll show you
the picture of this month's lady who's
reading and i'm doing actually the next
the next three gigs I'm doing or three
of my favorite clubs ever which are I'm
doing Madison Wisconsin comedy on state
next week to 21st through whatever or
the 19th through the 20 whatever it is
that Thursday Friday Saturday before
Christmas and then I got Christmas off
and then the first week of january i'm
an ACME my home club in minneapolis oh
great that's another great club and then
the week after that i'm in tacoma which
is one of my new favorite clubs in the
country to come
Washington Tacoma comedy club in Tacoma
Washington it's an amazing club they are
run by grown-ups who know how to run a
comedy club own tastic so it's amazing
so come and see me if you are in madison
wisconsin minneapolis minnesota or
tacoma washington in oh and I'm also
doing sketchfest and a live dork forest
in san francisco in january all right go
to Jackie Hays calm and look at things
all right guys what random me thank you
hopefully we'll see you at the screening
in Melbourne at Sheamus O'Toole's yes
and that is sold out though so hopefully
you already have your ticket yeah come
by and say hi and then of course
December twentieth at the Hollywood
improv and then still seats available
for that oh i just am setting this up i
will put the dates on there but uh
January sixteenth i'll be doing a show
at hawaiian brian's in beautiful
honolulu hawaii oh that's neat so that's
always a fun gig always a fun gay you
bring your surfboard your board up
serves all of the wonderful boards they
have there do they already already have
Lord so many know best shapers in the
world excellent words are great and then
i'll be at the improv in las vegas
februari 9 through 14 lake tahoe march
two through six so that's it guys thank
you for everything excellent we got a
lot of stuff coming up don't forget the
the improv show coming up of course said
that yes number 20 and the twentieth and
also there's still time to buy stuff in
the store for christmas delivery we can
we can guarantee christmas to worry up
until would we say bye-bye me if you
have to buy by the end of day on the
20th yes shipping the 21st is the last
day we can ship it priority right to you
by the 24th and we do have a discount
code yeah uh-huh that is holiday work it
and that will get you ten percent off
everything in the store including all of
Jackie's merchandise and I and even her
download movie as well all right I made
for special right yeah this will make an
excellent Horcrux yeah and I will if you
guys come to madison or Minneapolis or
tacoma and bring your comedy film nerds
book if i didn't already sign it i will
sign it again there you go where i'll
sign up for the first time again
just happened perfect that's exactly
what happens yeah we're all really on
time all right well thank you jackie i
think that is that name anymore it said
it those are the yeah there's those the
bigger thing huh thank you um Jackie
just knocked over our backup hard drive
haha um she doesn't know what that is
there's no that is bothers her cuz it's
not paper yeah we don't we don't have a
stenographer here backing up the show is
that what binary back box is that fine
alright a bonus up DVD closet with
Jackie Kashian my name is Graham Bell
and I'm Chris Mancini and as always
remember han shot first